what's popping observers it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is going to be a breakdown of
episode 6 of Rick and Morty season 7 a
clip Show episode that airs out the
dirty laundry of the Smith family so get
ready to stamp your adventure cards cuz
we about to jump into it gang and the
episode starts with Rick on the ground
drunk off of his old bony ass likely as
a result of the events of last episode
that saw Rick finally eliminate his
longtime enemy Rick Prime for the murder
in multiversal eraser of Rick's wife
Diane Rick is definitely feeling the
effects of having finally achieved his
life mission of Revenge and now he's
just using alcohol to numb the emptiness
inside while also of course helping Rick
deal with the fact that Rick Prime was
right about him stealing Rick Prime's
family in life Rick would not have the
family and the life that he has were it
not for Rick Prime all of that is just a
lot to deal for Rick which is why we see
him getting drunk and refusing to
Adventure at the beginning of this
episode Morty in an attempt to both
cheer up his grandpa and get back to the
space adventuring life finally Cashes in
on all of his Morty Adventure cards a
concept that first appeared earlier in
the series in season 3 episode 4 as part
of an agreement between Rick and Morty
that allows Morty to choose one in every
10 adventures and after Rick refuses to
honor his promise of letting Morty cash
in on any adventure of his choosing
Morty whips out his Adventure notes
which includes the names of all the
incidents that Morty has counted towards
the receipt of an adventure card stamp
on the front page of those Adventure
notes we can see zorila Death Race
memory planet with a sub arrow that says
memory of the memory Planet lab dooodle
brain Heist interplanetary Cricket World
Cup the aisle of the mortys Beanie Baby
zombie apocalypse two times apparently
that happened twice how does that happen
twice dark brunch which sounds like
something that would probably happen
during Agatha coven of chaos Regional
Plumbing convention takes one to no one
which Rick mentions directly getting
good at yo-yo tricks chicken sandwich
waffle and soda caned Gren business and
then of course their argument heats up
enough to force Rick to call in for an
emergency audit from The Observer which
is this universe's parody of the
watchers from Marvel Comics but instead
of big baby men The Observers appear to
be slices of cosmic geode Rock capable
of replaying the moments of every living
being in existence and later when the
Observer plays the truth or dare moment
from Morty's list we get a clear parody
of Zelda breath of the wild and tears of
the Kingdom video games with the shik
eye on the top of the temple and the
blue and orangee glow of both the temple
and the temple Centuries with those
Temple Knights themselves having been
inspired by the two Stone centries in
front of the Sacred Grove in Twilight
Princess and to the left of the temple
in the episode you can see a maze that
is apparently a parody of the low May
Labyrinth from breath of the wild and as
they approach those nights Rick comments
on how he believes the movements of the
Guardians from the breath of the Wild
games are predictable and boring which I
thought was hilarious and in the next
memory we get a flashback to Morty
getting Rick a western bacon
cheeseburger from Carl Jr a franchise
that Rick has apparently been banned
from for some mysterious reason probably
related to his favorite hobby of alcohol
and then in the following clip we get a
maximum overdrive with close scenario
which is of course a reference to the
Stephen King book turned 1986 movie
Maximum Overdrive which was a film about
a passing Comet over a planet causing
all the machines to revolt against
humanity and then when Rick is reading
the Whistler and Dixie Adventure title
on Morty's list
the words that he's reading aren't
actually on the paper that he's holding
as he's literally just holding that
front page that I broke down earlier and
the term Whistling Dixie is of course a
matchup of the phrase Whistling Dixie
and Whistler from the Blade movies with
the scene being a parody of whistler's
long rants about all the vampire killing
weapons that he makes you can actually
see blad signature gun and boomerangs
and Whistler suitcase full of weapons
and Rick and Morty of course are both
dressed up like Blade with Rick actually
wielding blad's blade then after after
this we get a flashback to when Morty
transformed into a boat while being
bullied at school referencing those
cybernetic implants that turn Morty into
a car that Rick reveals that he secretly
installed within Morty in season 2
episode 6 the Ricks must be crazy then
later after the Observer shames Rick for
not following his keto diet we get a
flashback to when Morty licks the
nostril of a cyborg parody of the great
AP Ape from the Dragon Ball anime before
we find out that Morty didn't even have
to do it in the first place it was all
just part of an ongoing series of Morty
bets that Rick apparently has with a
bunch of Rick variants at a pub that
they all meet up called The Salty Rick
the Morty bets on the wall that we can
see include Rick getting Morty to marry
Mr Poopy butthole which we saw in the
Morty's mindblowers episode which is why
it's crossed out Rick trying to get
Morty to believe that he's a ghost enter
a murder suicide with the president
common law marry a hippo chug salad
dressing become Santa Claus and drink
toilet water and then when we get that
invasion of the hottie snatchers clip
which is of course a parity of the
Invasion of the Body Snatchers you can
see a model in front of a red car and a
banner that says Servo which is of
course supposed to be a parity of the
Jaguar brand of Motor Vehicles as a
Servo is just a different kind of jungle
cat and later when we get a clip of
space Beth farting during a mission
briefing we can see that space Beth has
been working with her father's old
battle buddy bird person to help hunt
down high value GRL targets and then
when we get a clip of Morty stealing $20
from Rick's wallet you can see Rick's
license with a picture of a clearly
drunk Rick on the front making me really
want to see a flashback to the day that
Rick got his license because you know
that dude had to use some mind control
or some high-tech something to get that
damn license because that man was drunk
off of his ass that day then later after
Rick and Morty get arrested for the
murder of the Observer they mentioned
that they have done this similar type of
one-sided court trial situation before
but with giants which is a reference to
season 1 episode 5 me seeks and Destroy
when Rick and Morty get arrested for the
murder of a Giant and later when we get
a flashback to Rick giving Morty a bunch
of guns the last gun that Rick gives
Morty shoots out clones of the infamous
serial killer Jeffrey dmer before we get
a reference to the 1989 movie Pet
Cemetery based on the 1983 book by
Stephen King making this the second
Stephen King reference of the episode
then after this we get the Revelation
that this Rick and Morty killed the
variants of themselves who quickly
cameoed and Space Jam a new Legacy to
drop the Tasmanian devil off to the
basketball team and then when Rick
manages to hack into the Mainframe of
The Observers during the trial he pulls
up a memory of one of The Observers
selling a bunch of bootleg DVDs
featuring never beeseen movies that do
not exist in real life movies such as a
sequel to 2022 Babylon called more
Babylon an Amsterdam 4 which is a sequel
to the 2022 movie Amsterdam the infamous
canceled Batgirl movie which is super
funny a sequel to Oppenheimer called
Oppenheimer reum Avatar 3 and a sequel
to The Social Network called The Social
social network into the metaverse which
also of course doubles as an into the
spiderverse joke as well and finally the
episode of course ends with the reveal
that Morty's mortal enemy Cher has
escaped the planet that Rick and Morty
tried to abandon him on for the rest of
his Immortal Life and has sworn to spend
the rest of his waking days terrifying
Morty while simultaneously planning on
how to leave Morty stranded in the exact
same way that Morty did to him like I
honestly really do hope that this churro
becomes a reoccurring character in the
series because it would be so damn funny
for a new mortal enemy to be introduced
in the episode right after the episode
that Rick got rid of his old mortal
enemy Rick Prime but honestly I'm on
team chur because what Rick and Morty
did to that boy was so messed up they
gave him life and then put him on a
dying Planet which is technically what
my mom did to me but hey what are you
going to do but anyways that is it for
this breakdown of this super ridiculous
episode of Rick and Morty thank you guys
so much for watching and hey if you guys
want even more amazing Rick and Morty
content go check out Whitney Vision cuz
my girl Whitney van Lingham is breaking
down everything animation all the time
and Rick and Morty is literally her jam
and my God are Whitney's breakdowns Next
Level so after you watch this video head
on over to Whitney vision and check her
stuff out because Whitney is incredible
literally has the best cartoon
breakdowns in the business hands down
but anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter or Instagram
if you guys want to see me post some
weird [__] but most importantly don't
forget to follow heavy spoilers here on
YouTube because we're always uploading
great stuff that you don't want to miss
and hey if you got a free second feel
free to leave a like And subscribe
because that really helps the channel a
lot but yeah thanks again for watching
this video you guys are amazing and I
love you and it really makes me so happy
that you guys keep watching my videos
it's the best thing in the world and uh
yeah take it easy